bonsoir à tous bienvenue dans le 7-8
sport l'émission consacrée à l'actualité
sportive dans le département tout de
suite le sommaire de votre émission
cyclisme pour la septième année
consécutive la course paris-nice s'est
élancé depuis divine la ville de
conflans sainte honorine a accueilli ce
dimanche le prologue de l'épreuve les
détails dans ce magazine handball
féminin menti aux bretons ne s'est
lourdement incliné à domicile contre
octeville sur mer ce samedi les i
montano perdu 23 11 sur leur terrain ou
recevront dans quelques instants
l'entraîneur de l'équipe 1 bono philippe
et le vice président du club christophe
reading billard un tournoi international
de black ball étaient programmées tout
au long du week-end au centre sportif
des pyramides de voisins-le-bretonneux
plus de 400 participants dont les 32
meilleurs joueurs français qui sont
inscrits à cette compétition reportage à
suivre
et puis nous parlerons également de
cyclisme sur piste des championnats du
monde en ligne montrent un françois
pervis et la plaisir aux 110 clerc
étaient engagés dans la compétition
avant de parler de handball féminin avec
nos invités on commence ce magazine par
du cyclisme pour la septième année
consécutive la course paris-nice été
lancés depuis les yvelines
la ville de conflans sainte honorine
accueilli ce dimanche le prologue de
l'épreuve la course a été remportée par
l'australien mick milka michael matthews
pardon les images sont signées yves une
première c'est désormais une tradition
pour la septième année consécutive la
course cycliste paris nice organisé
jusqu'au 13 mars été lancés depuis les
yvelines cette année la ville de
conflans sainte honorine a été choisi
pour le prologue de cette soixante
quatorzième édition on est ravi d'être
là avec un circuit contre la montre qui
va être sportivement probant
le premier kilomètre je lisais long de
la seine et puis là la somme des
laveuses qu'il faudra escalader alors ce
sera certainement pas insurmontable pour
les coureurs de paris nice mais ça peut
créer quelques différences
une centaine de coureurs étaient
présents sur ce prologue épinoy parmi
les têtes d'affiché le public a pu
apercevoir les stars françaises romain
bardet tony gallopin ou encore
l'espagnol alberto contador
il ya un très beau plateau avec contador
en effet avec richie porte le tenant du
titre donc deux doubles ancien vainqueur
de paris-nice et puis également avec
ceux que j'appelle les pépés flingueurs
thomas voeckler et sylvain chavanel les
cours en français les plus populaires on
sera heureux de revoir dans le casting
de ce paris nice on retrouve un enfant
du pays l'irlandais nicolas roche a vécu
à conflans sainte honorine jusqu'à ses
12 ans depuis cinq six ans à chaque fois
ça se rapprochait on n'était pas très
loin de saint germain en laye on était
juste derrière et je sais moi y avait un
moment où on va tomber pile dessus
donc si c'était qu'une question de
patience et de temps mais c'est bien que
ça a été fait au moment où j'ai encore
quoi
l'australien michael matthews a remporté
ce prologue de 6,1 km ont devant son lot
au long des tom dumoulin d'une petite
seconde
après le prologue de ce dimanche le
départ de la première étape était
programmée aujourd'hui à condé sur vègre
un petit village évinois 2159 habitants
située près de ou dans le peloton
composé d'une centaine de coureurs est
ensuite passé aux alentours de
rambouillet avant de se diriger vers la
ville de vendôme dans le loir et cher
le coureur de la fdj arnaud démare a
emporté au sprint cette étape de 195 km
il a devancé ben swift d'ennasr boigny
au classement général l'australien
michael matthews conserve son maillot
jaune avec une seconde d'avancé sur le
hollandais tom dumoulin
on reste dans le cyclisme mais cette
fois ci sur piste un an après les cinq
médailles d'or glanées au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines lors du
championnat du monde
les français n'ont pas su rééditer leur
exploit à londres la semaine dernière
françois pervis qui ne s'était pas
aligné sur le kilomètre a perdu en 16e
de finale dans l'épreuve de vitesse
individuelle et lors des épreuves de
karine grégory baugé originaire de
maisons laffitte n'a pas franchi le
seuil des quarts de finale en vitesse
yves binois est également reparti sans
médaille sur les épreuves de vitesse par
équipes masculines le trio qu'ils
composaient avec kévin sireau et le
plaisir à michael d'almeida a été battu
pour la médaille de bronze par
l'allemagne chez les dames sandie clair
originaire de plaisir n'a pas franchi
les qualifications vitesse individuelle
en finale au final liquide
france se quitte londres avec zéro titre
mais avec deux médailles d'argent avec
le trappistes benjamin thomas et morgan
kneisky sur l'américaine il aurait
berton sur l'omnium
enfin quentin lafargue a remporté le
bronze sur le kilomètre pour débriefer
ces résultats nous avons téléphone
vincent jacquet le directeur technique
national qui revient tout juste de
londres bonsoir
vincent jacquet est ce que vous nous
entendez tout à fait bien ébauché oui je
vous entends alors on va rentrer tout de
suite dans le vif du sujet le bilan
est-il négatif sur ces championnats du
monde
non le bilan n'est pas négatif le bilan
n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qu'on
attendait on a encore comme on avait
amassé pas mal de fans de travail à b
mais c'est clair qu'on a sur les
épreuves sur lesquelles on a on appris
en 2015 ces défauts fait cruellement
défaut avec une grosse
contre-performance de françois pervis
hurler sur les deux les deux disciplines
donc c'était principalement le
spécialiste le terril la vitesse
individuelle par ailleurs vitesse paris
qui se place à la quatrième place de
l'échiquier international donc pour
l'instant je serais tenté de dire que
c'est notre place
pas de surprise par rapport à ça puisque
la saison a été compliqué dans les
coupes du monde avec des blessures qu'il
a fait
qin a fallu accompagner palier et puis
une bonne remontée en puissance de
grégory baugé sur les épreuves
habituelles de justesse avec certes pas
dans le pape au final est le dernier
quart mais au match et une réelle envie
d'être présent sur sur les prochains les
prochaines semaines et les prochains
mois notamment portion claqué espère un
petit peu les occupants avec le groupe
lensois bien vie sexuelle aspects très
positifs et la jeune génération qui
match avec lorie berton qui me ramène
l'argent sur un compte qui les benjamins
dommages sur la réalité ni ciel qui nous
amène l'argent
ce formidable essor des british avec
avec le meeting avait dit sean qui n'est
pas libre et le bronze pour quentin
l'apparition des produits km qui n'est
pas foncièrement très spécial une l1 sur
un tiennent compte et qu'on vit une
crise éventuelle compliqué des montots
côté cure pour pour un collectif mais tu
travailles à engager des données qu'on a
qu'on a pu collecter les débris ce qu'on
a su en trois jours et malgré l'avancé
sur maintenant l'état d'esprit qu'on
souhaite mettre en place avec l'équipe
de france pour aller chercher les plus
brillants elle championnat vont à ces
championnats
championnats du monde vont peser dans la
section pour les jeux olympiques tout
compte pour la sélection dans les jeux
olympiques un jeu je le rappelle les
différents critères que l'on se rend
compte par rapport au rapport aux trois
finales sont des critères d'une part
d'expérience internationale des titres
internationaux on recule la france était
là à voir l'une des premières nations
sur sur des épreuves du sprint et je
pense qu'aujourd'hui on est on est aussi
affiner notre préparation à la
planification d'entraînement de
récupération des médecins du monde ne
pouvoir défendre ses chances contre
depuis déjà quelques quelques années et
filles de tous sentis précisément sur
cette dernière n'est pas bon on l'avait
un ancien champion du monde et terre un
point d'étape aussi un travail et un
point d'observation et les observations
des différentes nations qui sont nos
principales trad on n'est pas
aujourd'hui à leur niveau mais notre
marge de progression est intéressante
on a fait du bon temps il n'ya précieux
dramatique et on se concentre sur notre
pièce tu fais maintenant dans une phase
beaucoup plus serré beaucoup plus précis
je me suis payé beaucoup plus
individuelle
miclo pour pour accompagner ce collectif
a rappelé pourra regarder quoi qu'il en
soit les annonces des élections ne se
feront pas avant le 4 avril puisque nous
proposerons au comité national olympique
et sportif français
d'autres partitions park 4 avril merci
beaucoup vincent jaques qui en soit à
toute l'équipe de france de france de
rebondir cet été aux jeux après cette
large page cyclisme on passe au handball
une défaite qui fait mal dans la course
au maintien promu cette année en
nationale une l'équipe senior féminine
de montier montois s'est très lourdement
incliné samedi sur son terrain contre
octeville sur mer le score 23 11
conséquence lésigny monteyne son
dernière du classement pour nous parler
de la situation du club nous recevons
sur ce plateau le nouveau coach bruno
filipe et le vice président de l'ès
montignac balle christophe reding
bonsoir mon saut alors nous allons
revenir sur cette rencontre
23 à 11 le score est très lourd monopoly
effectivement le score est très lourd
avec avec une équipe d'autres villes de
très solides avec un groupe qui compte
en ce qui concerne montigné donc très
jeune et qui apprend qu'il est en train
d'apprendre donc doucement mais
qu'est-ce qui n'a pas fonctionné sur
cette rencontre
c'est vraiment l'impact physique
d'autres villes étaient plus importants
que que le nôtre physique augmente donc
on a été dominés on a tenu à peu près 10
les 17 premières minutes et nous avions
deux filles donc des piliers de l'équipe
bianca et
un fanni qui ont joué blessé hélas donc
et c'est un petit peu mal passé pour
nous en seconde mi temps
oxman était largement supérieur à
montigny il n'y a pas vraiment de
regrets du coup à avoir sur cette
rencontre
sur la deuxième mi temps n'ont rien à
dire sur la première mi temps où l'on
peut voir des on peut avoir des regrets
parce qu'on a fait plus que jeu égal et
en deuxième mi temps donc on s'est
affaibli physiquement ça ferait ding
cette défaite peut avoir un impact
conséquent sur la deuxième partie de
saison
alors cette fin de saison même un impact
certes aujourd'hui c'est sûr que
l'objectif qui est fixé aujourd'hui à
l'équipe et à vous nos philippe le nom
de recruter c'est quand même c'est le
maintien donc on n'a pas cette ambition
de maintenir cette équipe nous et ce
fleuron en fait du club au plus haut
niveau national
rien n'est perdu non plus
c'est clair il ya encore des matches à
jouer et il ya aussi un potentiel de
matches à gagner donc
actuellement on demande aussi bien à nos
joueuses canaux coach
notre coach et puis les préparateurs
physiques d'être présent là dessus et on
escompte bien pouvoir se maintenir sur
la fin de l'année la fin de la saison
je pense que les points on les contraint
à l'issue donc là les points vous en
avez 22 pour l'instant le premier non
relégable est à un petit point
tout est jouable finalement tout est
jouable tout est jouable et on a
vraiment l'ambition en fait en tout cas
de passer devant
carquefou landi voilà notre objectif
c'est là c'est sûr c'est pas d'être dans
les premiers mais c'est vraiment de se
maintenir
vous y croyez vous tiens absolument
surtout que depuis depuis quinze jours
on travaille des fils travaille beaucoup
s'investissent beaucoup elles elles sont
avides d'apprendre et de mettre en
application hélas contre octeville sas a
pas pu le faire mais moi je reste
persuadé comme le disait christophe que
les matchs qui vont être à notre portée
il arrive au mois d'avril le mois
d'avril va être capital je pense que ça
va le faire puisque les filles vont être
là vous avez remplacé philippe l'étrange
il y à il ya un mois à peu près est ce
que vous allez continuer son travail le
travail qu'il avait commencé évidemment
philippe aujourd'hui donc travailler à
bien travailler donc avec avec ce groupe
maintenant le problème entre entre
philippe et
et les filles donc nous on a décidé de
l'occulté complètement de manière à
rentrer à ne pas perdre de temps dans la
mission qui nous incombe vous allez
garder sa philosophie de jeu qui était
par exemple le redoublement de passes
philosophie de jeu aujourd'hui ce qui
nous manque essentiellement c'est
d'essayer de franchir cette marche donc
je pense qu'il a été sous-estimé entre
la nationale 2 la nationale 1 par
exemple des séances vidéos des séances
vidéo obligatoire pour préparer donc les
matchs professionnalisme un petit peu
plus ou un petit peu plus de
professionnalisme qui correspondent à la
nationale je pense pourquoi avoir choisi
bruno philippe christophe rémy alors
déjà premièrement c'est très simple il
était disponible
ça c'est une première première réponse
mais avant avant bien sûr il reste en
bien plus sérieux c'est dû à son niveau
de compétence il a quand même exercé
dans un niveau professionnel ou plus
haut niveau amateur également aussi bien
sur le secteur féminin que masculin donc
son expérience en fait
peut nous apporter beaucoup au sein du
club comme il vient de le dire un
instant c'est vrai que la marche entre
une de henin est assez grande
on se rend compte trois entraînements
par semaine pour un niveau amateur
ça va très bien sûr de la n2 mais à
partir de là et d'un coup on voit fur et
à mesure les équipes rencontrent et ben
il manque au moins un entraînement ça
c'est ça c'est certain donc en fait il
faut un moment donné ben on est vraiment
au pied en fait du monde professionnel
et aussi à nous nous adapter par rapport
à ça et quelles sont les erreurs qu'il
ne faudra pas reproduire sur cette fin
de saison
selon vous je pense clairement et c'est
l'engagement l'engagement de chacun
quand on s'engage au plus haut niveau
un moment donné je pense qu'il faut
vraiment être conscient que c'est le
plus haut niveau et c'est à dire qu'il
ya des sacrifices à faire pour les uns
et pour les autres et ça c'est vrai que
c'est pas évident c'est pas évident
quand je pense pour une joueuse qui peut
être maman ou une joueuse qui a un
travail à côté où il faut répondre
présent aussi bien sur les entraînements
que sur l'image
quand on est à ce niveau-là c'est faire
beaucoup de sacrifices et ça en fait
c'est là-dessus qu'il faut qu'il faut
vraiment remercier ces jeunes filles
parce qu' une vraie volonté mais ça
passe au delà de la passion et je pense
que ça c'est important et elles l'ont
toutes elles ont bien conscience de
sarah et elles ont aujourd'hui ils ont l
on présente une peut dire ça dans le
jargon une vraie gnac et je pense que
c'est pour ça qu'on fait c'est cet
élément qui nous permettra nous vraiment
de lui maintenir merci à toi de les
passer sur ce plateau on continue à
suivre avec assiduité montier vous
retourner sur tv fil 78 après leur
handball on va parler à billard dans ce
magazine
une fois n'est pas coutume nous allons
parler billard dans ce set 8 sport le
tournoi national black ball étaient
programmées tout au long du week-end au
centre sportif des pyramides à voisins
le bretonneux plus de 400 joueurs dont
les 32 meilleurs joueurs français ont
participé à cette compétition roma
respini à pour le montage
de la précision du sang froid et de la
concentration des ingrédients
indispensables pour remporter le tournoi
national de black ball de
voisins-le-bretonneux la compétition
était organisée du vendredi 5 au
dimanche 7 mars au centre sportif des
pyramides les règles du black ball sont
aujourd'hui les plus pratiqués dans
l'hexagone il ya six trous il y a
cette vie jaune sept baies rouges une
bille noire envy blanche le but du jeu
est de rentrer à à l'aide de la bille
blanche essaient de rentrer les cette
bille de sa couleur soit les jeunes
soient les rouges et laminoirs an
dernier en direct coûts en bande s'en
remettra blanche ça a été créé en
angleterre
justement pour avoir une petite table de
billard qu'on puisse installer dans des
salles à droite à gauche et donc se
jouer dans le monde entier au total plus
de 400 participants dont les 32
meilleurs joueurs français se sont
affrontés sur l'e40 billard installé
dans la salle
c'est une étape 1 du championnat france
doc c'est une qualification on vient ici
pour gagner le tournoi aussi pour
prendre des points pour se qualifier
pour le graal c'est à dire le titre de
champion de france
le numéro un français christophe lambert
a été éliminé en huitièmes de finale
dans la catégorie masters
la compétition a été remportée par
christophe thébaud un joueur originaire
de blois
coup de projecteur à présent sur le club
de football féminin de montigny le
bretonneux le club est actuellement à la
6e place du classement sur douze équipes
dans le championnat de division honneur
pour nous parler du club nous recevons
sur ce plateau le président olivier a
bien cucchi le référent du football
féminin roger un bonhomme et la coach
valérie merci bonsoir
alors je le disais précédemment vous
êtes dans le ventre mou on peut dire du
classement c'était c'est une surprise
c'était prévisible sa place c'était déjà
espéré en début de saison car on a quand
même un groupe qui est assez jeune une
surprise au vu du début de saison qu'on
fait non je pense même pas
au vu des matches qu'on a pu faire et si
on n'aurait pas eu un manque d'effectif
comme ont eu cette année je pense qu'on
aurait pu lui même pu viser la troisième
ou quatrième place le club duc on disait
juste précédemment le club a été sur le
podium pendant de nombreuses journées en
début de saison ce n'est pas justement
rageant de se retrouver 6e
quand on arrive dans le sprint final
finalement ce qui est difficile c'est
oui c'est un peu rageant parce qu'il est
difficile quoi par rapport au manque
d'effectifs
syfy qui manquent de deux joueuses trois
joueuses automatiquement match perdu et
le championnat est tellement serré
suffit de perdre un match
vous perdez automatiquement plusieurs
places au jeune homme
oui vous êtes déçus ou de cette place si
vous pensez montini plus à faire mieux
cette saison et je pense que les filles
sont félicités comme l'ensemble des gens
du staff
donc on peut encore progresser si on
finit nous quatrième mois je pense que
ça serait quelque chose de très très
très bien parce qu'on joue quand même
des équipes b d'un club en première
division de deux autres en deuxième
division donc sait jamais c'est jamais
facile
vous pensez qu'il va continuer à
surperformer depuis début de la saison
où finalement le niveau réel de l'équipe
on respire façon de jouer sincèrement
qu'une quatrième cinquième place
on a félicité tous l'ensemble donc vous
avez marqué 26 buts cette saison vous
avez encaissé 32
finalement c'est peut-être un petit peu
trop pour pour viser la montée
pas forcément car en plus c'est pas
notre image m parce que notre force
actuelle cette année c'est vraiment la
défense donc c'est vrai que ça peut être
cette fête
étonnant mais on a une très très bonne
défense donc c'est vrai que d'avoir 32
32 buts s'est passé pas à notre image
par rapport à la défense c'est trop le
coach est bon en fait qu'en 6 6 32 buts
oui dans une saison c'est trop mais si
on regarde bien sûr les 32 buts yonhap
tête 11 ou 12 qu'on a pris contre celles
qui sont premières donc là on est ce
qu'on a on a vraiment un écart avec elle
donc on a craqué défensivement et le
problème c'est que bon on a encore une
joueuse ellis qui est blessé voilà comme
on disait tout à l'heure
comme cette année on n'a pas d'équipé
malheureusement c'est que dès qu'il
manque des joueuses en plus à certains
postes clés il est difficile après de
tenir la route ce sont des erreurs
généralement d'un défenseur ou des
quatre défenseurs ou ce sont plutôt des
erreurs de bloc équipe où on laisse trop
d'espacé finalement l'adversaire souvent
je pense pas que c'est des erreurs
défensives
je pense que un moment donné de trop
subir la défense subit subi il me
donnait au milieu on craque donc un
recul est automatiquement un moment
donné là
la défense peut plus les filles sont
elles ne sont elles pas assez solidaires
peut-être roger walsh et je suis passé
que lé tout mais bon comme on vient de
le dire le président on a pris je crois
à 12 buts en contre deux équipes donc un
match où on avait joué je vie dit il y
avait quand même 3 international qui
était en équipe b
donc c'est quand même difficile pour les
gamines comme chez nous qu'on va lire on
peut le dire 75 % des filles sont en
dessous de 20 ans ont massé c'est
difficile au bout d'un moment on se bat
on se bat et puis un moment qu'on passe
à ça craque non c'est moi je pense qu'il
ya une bonne bonne ambiance quelque
chose de poser est quelque chose de très
bien pour l'avenir vous et dans quelle
optique à présent vous êtes dans une
optique de former l'équipe pour la
saison prochaine où vous êtes dans
l'optique de toujours viser le podium
c'est pour cette année l'objectif c'est
de finir à la meilleure place déjà donc
je pense que
la quatrième place moi ça me ferait
plaisir personnellement et je pense que
ça ferait plaisir au staff aussi après
si on finit 4e c'est aussi parce qu'elle
valérie avait fait un super travail avec
les joueurs car en début de saison ce
n'est pas forcément ce qu'on voulait
mais on commence déjà à travailler sur
l'avenir donc l'année prochaine pour
nous d'être très important de refaire
une équipe 2 donc parce que une équipe
première sans équipe réserve c'est
compliqué donc l'objectif c'est ça et on
continue aussi de travailler sur les
jeunes car on les jeunes c'est l'avenir
pour cette fin de saison vous allez
peut-être intégrer des jeunes dans
l'effectif du coup alors le prenez vous
préparer l'année prochaine et les allées
les prochaines années on peut les
intégrer aux entraînements mais pas en
match
parce qu'il ya un nouveau règlement
c'est à dire que les u19 actuelle à
montigny ce sont des u17 et il faut des
surclassements or là aucune un
surclassement donc sinon je pense qu'on
les aurait intégré déjà dans le
championnat mais vous allez faire avec
ce groupe là du coup puisque jusqu'à la
fin de saison c'est pour ça quand on
disait qu'en fin d'année déjà le but
c'était de garder nos joueuses actuelles
déjà il vivait en co chief dans trois
ans où sera le club plus haut selon
comme une fois je l'avais déjà dit sur
notre plateau c'est naturellement vise
toujours plus haut je pense que montigny
j'espère que ce sera un très bon club
formateur avec
un football féminin avec un petit peu
plus de 150 licenciés
moi personnellement ça me ferait plaisir
je pense que roger il faut beau féminin
depuis longtemps aussi
après au niveau du niveau 6
ici la fédération 16 recréer une
troisième division je pense qu'on serait
à notre place sur sa troisième division
car on serait même temps club formateur
donc après bizet la d2 comme j'ai déjà
dit après il faut avoir des
investissements il faut il faut que ça
suive quoi monter pour redescendre
l'année d'après c'est c'est bien pour
l'année en cours
mais c'est dommage pour l'avenir merci à
tous les trois années passées sur ce
plateau on vous souhaite de finir
évidemment le plus haut possible à 4éme
place aux libéraux cucchi on passe
maintenant à l'essentiel de l'actualité
à sportive
c'est un petit scandale dans le monde de
l'ovalie vinoy chevreuse qui va
affronter joué-lès-tours le 31 janvier
dernier à l'occasion de la 12e journée
du championnat de fédérale 3 est au
coeur d'une affaire selon les yvelinois
chevron a gagné sur le terrain de 12 à
11 mais l arbitre a marqué sur la
feuille de match que joué-lès-tours
avait remporté le match 13 à 12
les responsables chevron 1 n'ont pas
signé la feuille de match ont déposé un
recours la commission a été saisie
je vois est passé à jeudi dernier devant
les instances on l'écoutait l'entraîneur
de l'équipe aubry strong est évidemment
à très énervé c'est en dehors du jeu
c'est en dehors du rugby tout ça c'est
c'était vraiment pour que bat pour que
ce soit fait et bien fait voilà alors
après si le match est annulé s'il ya un
point chacun si on doit le rejouer voilà
pourquoi pas après si ça reste en l'état
on sera scandalisés mais ne pourra pas
faire grand chose d'autre quoi
j'aimerais bien être optimiste j'espère
vraiment une idée de justice ans et
voilà c'est ça après
après quoi qu'il en soit on finira notre
saison on va tout faire et nous reste
quatre matches on doit prendre le
maximum de points à gagner voilà on
verra la décision n'est pas encore
connue la commission devrait donner sa
réponse avant la fin de la semaine
on continue par du handball équipes
seniors du chéné qui lutte pour sa
survie en nationale 2 s'est inclinée à
domicile ce week-end contre saintes sur
le score de 23 à 27
au classement les chais désir reste
avant dernier du classement à huit
journées de la fin de la saison les
lillois comptent quatre points de retard
sur la place de premier non relégable le
maintien s'annonce compliquée et on
termine par un rendez-vous les
traditionnelles régates de versailles
organisé par le cercle nautique de la
ville sont programmés ce dimanche 13
mars sur le grand canal du château les
courses minimes vétérans seniors et
juniors seront organisées au total une
centaine de sportifs devraient
participer à l'épreuve le public
le public peut assister gratuitement aux
épreuves c'est la fin de cette fuite
sport merci d'avoir suivi très belle
soirée sur tv fil 78